hi there Steve Kaufman here I'm off to
Montreal tomorrow morning there's a
conference there on multilingualism and
cognitive processes and so forth for two
days at McGill University and I hope to
learn things about language learning
that can be useful for my own language
learning things that I can share with
you here at my channel things that might
help us improve link so I am very much
looking forward to the participating in
this conference in Montreal today I want
to talk about a comment that was made to
my previous video where I talked about
you know the wisdom of learning more
than one language at the same time
recognizing that people have their own
preferences some people are happy doing
this I only said that I tend to want to
concentrate on one language give it at
least 80% of my attention because I
become so obsessed with learning that
language that I can't really pull myself
away from that language to learn another
language but other people are happily
are quite happy learning three or four
languages and there was an interesting
comment from a Peter Brown and he said
the key is triangulation otherwise long
will waste a lot of time contemplating
the navel of their native languages
whenever possible want to study a
foreign language through the medium of
foreign language another foreign
language for instance this morning I've
cited both Chinese and Indonesian
through the medium of German later the
morning and study Romanian with the
French as a meal book thus I didn't
waste any time contemplating my American
English navel interesting comment
because it's completely different to
what I do and I think this illustrates
the extent to which language learning is
a personal thing my own view is first of
all that I wouldn't study Chinese
Indonesian and Romanian in the same day
but I'm not saying that Peter shouldn't
do so that's entirely a personal thing
and second of all I think that the
question of you know studying
be through language see for me has no
resonance it makes no sense to me
whatsoever because my goal when I'm
learning a language is to get into the
target language as soon as possible as
much as possible so I spend very little
time reading say grammatical
explanations and it wouldn't matter to
me that's for this way the grammatical
explanations either they're in a
language that I know very well which
could be say English or French or
Japanese because I used some Japanese
material for studying Korean or if it's
in language I don't know very well
then it just confuses me even more to be
referring to some other language that I
don't fully understand to explain
dramatical concepts that I'm gonna have
a hard time understanding anyway
so I wouldn't do that similarly with
dictionaries because obviously I use
dictionaries we have dictionaries that
link my dictionaries that link are set
to English because English gives me the
quickest most concise and clear
indication of the various possible
meanings of this new word I won't
understand that word until I have met
that word in many different contexts so
eventually it's seeing that word in
different contexts that's gonna enable
me to understand what it means how its
used what other words is used together
with the grammatical translation I
prefer it in English some people though
feel that you have to have a you know a
monolingual dictionary I never use
monolingual dictionary because if I
don't know the language so well then I
could use one but at that point I'm
already you know I know the language
well enough but while I'm learning the
language I don't want to be looking at a
explanation of a term that contains
words that I don't understand or where
the explanation is somehow obtuse to me
I want some clear hint and that's the
term we use a link for a dictionary
definition it's only a hint as to what
the meaning that of that word is the
full scope of that word and how it's
used in the meaning has to come from
constant exposure to the word in context
and the bulk of my language learning
activity is listening and reading in the
target language so whatever language I
am using as my intermediary the
dictionary language or the grammar
reference is almost irrelevant because I
spent the overwhelming amount of my time
in the target language and so I believe
that people do whatever they want to do
but I am convinced that your attitude
your flexibility your interest in the
language the time you spend meaningful
time with the language not watching or
listening to stuff that you don't
understand but meaningful time and
developing the ability to notice those
are the key issues and so whether you
use a signal in French or some third
language to do your you know for your
dictionary definitions or grammatical
explanations to me is quite irrelevant
it's the three keys that are most
important your attitude meaningful time
with the language and developing the
ability to notice and I think whether
you use an English grammar book and I
would normally recommend be careful I
might cut out here because the last
couple of times my imovie basically
conked out at five minutes and thirty
seconds so if i conk out goodbye
otherwise i'll continue talking for as
long as i can so you know whatever you
use as your reference language to my
mind is fine my preference is my own
language my preference if I for example
I recommend to people even people
studying at link that they get
themselves a small starter book or maybe
several teach yourself colloquial a
similar whatever it might be and
preferably and similarly with a grammar
book preferably to your own language
because that's going to be clearest to
you or to a language that you speak very
very well that's my advice but I am no
doubt that Peter Brown is an
accomplished language learner and the
interesting thing is that his comment
attracted 27 thumbs up one of the most
popular comments I've ever
had on my you know YouTube channel here
so I may be out of touch with the
mainstream a lot of people think that
that's a great idea
personally and I think for the average
language learner I would not recommend
doing that I would recommend that you
know get two or three different starter
books but back to your own language and
then get away from those as soon as you
can and get into just the target
language I never like to listen to any
other language but the target language
and get immersed in that target language
and the bulk of certainly of my learning
time is spent sort of meaningfully
engaged with the target language that
means that whatever I listen to I can
read I have a text and that text I can
study it at link and laughs I can look
up words and phrases I can review these
words and phrases and flashcards I can
listen again I can read again so that
this is meaningful content and hopefully
interesting content and so I spend my
the bulk of my learning time with that
kind of material in the target language
with reference to a dictionary in my
language or language like French which I
know very very well so very interesting
to me to have this comment from a person
who is obviously an experienced language
learner and who has the support of a lot
of people who follow my YouTube channel
and I feel that you know the key is
triangulation this is his term because
triangulation I looked it up normally
implies you know determining the
position of you know position a with
reference to position B and C he uses it
for language learning but he says
otherwise one will waste a lot of time
contemplating a naval of their native
language to me
I spent very little time with my name
language I don't think that's true but
that's not to say that I don't think it
works for him and for the 27 people who
gave it a some thumbs up here at my
channel so it is interesting that we can
all be a passion of language
and have very different approaches so
there you have it I've sort of a
follow-up on the issue of learning more
than one language at the same time thank
you for listening bye for now